are the linguistic experts at Oxford
University press come up with the word
of the year but this year they've done
it a bit differently proposing instead a
short list of three words and getting
the public to vote on them the words in
question are metaverse a hypothetical
virtual reality environment in which
users interact with one another and
their surroundings in an immersive way
hashtag I stand with used on social
media to express solidarity with a
specific cause group person Etc and
Goblin mode a type of behavior which is
unapologetically self-indulgent lazy
greedy or slovenly typically in a way
that rejects social norms and
expectations perhaps unsurprisingly it's
Goblin mode that came out the clear
winner
its surge came earlier this year the
actress Julia Fox quoted as saying her
former boyfriend Kanye West didn't like
her in Goblin mode something she didn't
actually even say but the idea of living
the goblin life took off on social media
Oxford's experts suggested might be a
reaction to the social strictures of
covid-19 lockdowns though they traced
its first usage in this way back to
2009. some people probably just thought
it was a uh going with that idea of uh
slightly gleefulness that they thought
it was a relatively fun choice or that
it provided them with a word for
something they'd been doing but they
didn't know they've been that it was
called that certainly the fascination
with goblins is nothing new Oxford's own
J.R.R Tolkien conjured them in his Lord
of the Rings goblins and gargoyles burst
forth from the stonework of almost every
other building but have the humans on
the streets below heard of goblin mode
gobbling modes Goblin mode no any guess
as to what it might mean turn into a
goblin yeah
is that is that a type of behavior that
you occasionally indulge in yes I hope I
can't identify with that so it doesn't
sound like a very positive thing but
very often we don't look after ourselves
so I think that's quite a good idea
sometimes other institutions have chosen
more serious words of 2022 for
Merriam-Webster it was gaslighting for
the Collins Dictionary it was Perma
crisis so is there something peculiar to
our times that makes us want to sum them
up like this
people change language by voting with
their feet or with their males because
they choose which words they're going to
use in everyday life or in particular
situations and that's how language
evolves we were going to interview some
more people but a it was pretty cold and
miserable and B I felt the journalistic
impulse to try Goblin mode for myself so
rather than think of a pithy
thought-provoking final line I decided
to eat some churros they were nice Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera Oxford